as the covered 19 epidemic sweeps across
the world it's been accompanied by a
tsunami of misinformation
drink lemon and by covenant salt water
clear Akane
hold your grass over it hands against to
check if your lawn is hell so if you
keep sipping hot water at a time when
reliable information is vital for Public
Health fake news about kovat 19 might be
spreading even faster than the facts we
are not just fighting an epidemic we're
fighting an info Deming fake news
spreads faster and more easily than this
virus and is just as dangerous
researchers across the globe are working
to understand how misinformation spreads
and new models suggest that while the
fight against fake news can seem
hopeless it might not take too much
effort to take the balance the Reuters
Institute at Oxford University has been
looking at samples of fake news picked
up by international fact-checkers sir
this is Jay Scott Brennan I think before
we started III would have guessed that
most of the claims had to do with health
information or help misinformation but
what we saw was that the most common
type of claim had to do with the actions
or policies of public authorities Scott
and his team analyzed the content origin
and reach of 225 pieces of fake news
about 60% of the content involved
recontextualizing reworking or reframing
you know a grain of truth or a burnings
you know true fact in a way that it was
no longer true
for instance one vidiian claimed to show
clothes in the center of we had at the
height of the pandemic with text
implying they were attracted by dead
bodies in fact this video was from
another city in China thousand miles
away while it did show crows those crows
being right in this city had nothing to
do with pandemic at all the team also
found that mainstream media was not
exempt from spreading fake news we did
see a significant amount of
misinformation in the sample that was on
television
things like press conferences or
presidential debates that could also be
a very significant channel of this type
of misinformation present at the
University of East Anglia virologist
Paul Hunter has been studying the damage
caused by misinformation since 2015 when
he saw the impacts of fake news on the
Ebola outbreak in West Africa we were
hearing reports there that people were
believing this was a deliberate attack
by the government against dissenters and
there were actually episodes of
healthcare workers being murdered as a
result and indeed subsequent research
showed that people who believed these
lies were less likely to do things to
protect their lives Paul joined forces
with statistician Julie Brainard to
model how misinformation affects the
spread of a disease each one of those
little people has their own little
probabilities attached to them about the
behavior they're going to do which is
meant to reflect that they all make
slightly different decisions the
individuals in the model make decisions
about whether or not to believe fake
news whether or not to pass it on and
whether to change their behavior as a
result potentially putting themselves at
higher risk of catching or passing on
the disease all these decisions are
based on data collected from a whole
range of peer-reviewed studies from
various historical disease outbreaks
changing the parameters of the model and
running it thousands of times gave Paul
and Julie an insight into the power of
fake news during an epidemic something I
didn't expect was how small the change
had to be in the information balance and
I only had to tilt that ever so slightly
make it 60 percent good advice and 40%
bad advice to sort of cancel out the
effects of the bad advice
the w-h-o have already taken note of
Paul and Julie's findings in their
communication strategy when I look at my
social media right now I can tell that's
the strategy they're using they're just
flooding the system with the
good-quality safe solid information
meanwhile governments and public
authorities
thing mixed results in the fight against
fake news the fact that there's so much
of this misinformation about public
authorities it could be very difficult
for these organizations to try and
dispel you know this misinformation so
that's where independent fact checkers
who are not associated with these public
authorities can do really important work
according to Scott's research people are
beginning to question online news
sources they're making decisions not to
pass things on and choosing new sources
which they consider to be more reputable
all of which Paul and Julie's model
suggests will make a big difference what
I've shown in principle is how people
being resistant about advice and I've
called it immunized here but it's not
against disease it's against bad
information being resistant not sharing
the advice not believing it not acting
on it
those people can actually slow down that
advice that might encourage people into
unsafe behavior I think to me the most
important conclusions of the work is
that you can think about misinformation
and disinformation in the same way that
you think about the actual virus itself
even being able to reduce some of the
misinformation by about 30% might be
enough to actually substantially reduce
the impact and hopefully thereby save
lives
[Music]